what's the meaning of this whole thing
what's the meaning of life
now you're not allowed to say i don't
know okay
um you can
be just like your dad and say let me
just give my two cents
take it for you whatever it's worth take
it or leave it it's probably worth
nothing
piddle on the ground
um
uh do you i mean what why are we here is
it
it's just busily creating all these
kinds of things
worrying about things having kids
i
my purpose at least right now
is
to wake up
and try to
bring light love to the world
light love to myself
and have integrity
that's
my purpose
um
the ultimate purpose of life
that i guess that's my ultimate purpose
of life i i i don't know what happens
when i die
ayahuasca gave me some sense that
there's more to be known
i'm sure there are other things in life
that would give me that that i'm and i'm
lurking i'm looking for it i'm a seeker
like i'm
i'm always looking for the next
something to give me hope in something
more even if so i could just
not [ __ ] my kids when they ask me
that question and be like you know what
i really don't know i i want to not know
more
if that makes sense i don't want to like
i want to see things that make me
confused
that make me question what i already
knew like i
am like
when i meet an atheist who comes up to
me and they're like atheism atheism
atheism
it's just as laughable to me as when i
meet the mormon who comes up and they're
like mormonism mormonism mormonism i'm
like
how did how do anyone how do you guys
know that like
like
and uh you know
so you feel like you're doing some
through all your travels or all the
people you meet you feel like you're
still keeping your eyes open and your
heart open to
sort of discover
discover something new like the
ayahuasca experience
that there might be there might be
deeper truths out there
yeah and and i want to find them and i
want to surround myself with people who
are just looking for it i'm not i'm not
interested in people who are just
looking to point fingers at each like i
life is so short i'm looking for it's
one of the reasons that i want to meet
with you is i was like wow
lex really seems like he's on a journey
to find truth and that humility for me
is same thing with rick it drew me to
rick it was like i really i i see that
and i identify with it and that's what
i'm looking for there's the final song
on our record our new record that's
coming out
the chorus goes um
and this is like this is my best answer
to what to what you're asking
um
the course goes
take it easy on me i need some lullaby
they tell me heaven's just a lie well
i'm not surprised tell me that you know
no you don't yeah you're just like me
can we just hope for the best take it
easy
so that's it for me it's like i'm in a
place where i'm like
i don't know
tell me you know i don't i'm not gonna
believe you maybe you do i'm not gonna
believe it but
like just be easier on each other and
like try to find truth wherever it may
lie but above all know that we don't
know jack [ __ ]
i think that's a mic drop moment dan
thank you so much you're an incredible
human i love that you share with the
world
the darkness
of your mind of your life experience and
the beautiful light you've shown to the
world so
it's a huge honor and thank you for
spending your valuable time good luck on
the tour thanks man thanks for having me
you